bonjour monsieur dernier bonjour
j'espère que vous entendez bien je me
vais me permettre de vous présenter en
quelques mots même si je me doute que
oui voila je n'apprendrai a pris aux
internautes et puis là nous aurons un
temps des changes peut être d'une demi
heure et ensuite on prendra est question
à des internautes
à l'issue des échanges alors monsieur
vernet votre parcours politique est
l'illustration de votre engagement pour
la france et pour l'europe
en effet vous avez été élu local en
savoir vous à 17 ans le conseil général
et d'albertville en 1992 avec le jean
claude qui vous êtes vous avez d'élus
nationale quelquefois ministre deux fois
commissaire européen
vous faites bien parti on peut dire de
ces rares personnes de ces rares à
chaleur et l'altitude où ils connaissent
chaque échelon territorial de notre
système démocratique et institutionnel
en octobre 2016 vous avez repris du
service à bruxelles d'abord pour
conduire les négociations du bric site
au nom de l'union européenne puis 20
puis au début de l'année pour négocier
les balles sur avec les futures
relations avec le royaume uni le
résultat du référendum britannique de
joint 2016 a été un séisme
alors moi je fais partie des déjeuners
européen et stratos donc re pays
convaincu et c'est vrai qu'on
s'attendait pas et ont eu du mal à
imaginer qu'un jour un état elle décidé
de quitter l'union européenne et donc
c'est vrai que c'est sacré cas une sorte
de onde de choc et donc je propose que
pendant la demi-heure qui vient on
échange sur ce que vous appelez les deux
fais du bric citent d'abord l'accord de
retrait d'une part vous avez négocié
pendant près de trois ans et qui
correspond à un brick site politique
pour reprendre vos termes
et puis le bric site économique qui pose
la question des relations instaurées
entre le royaume
est devenu un état tiers et l'union
européenne à 27
et puis on prendra ensuite quelques
questions je hais ce que déjà sur le
principe cela je suis naturellement
votre disposition bonjour rebecca et
bonjour ap
chacune et chacun de ceux qui nous font
l'amitié de se joindre à nous et d'être
online pour ce dialogue
bonjour aux élus parlementaires
européens nationaux locaux du modem et
aux militants aussi qui qui nous
écoutent peut-être d'autres personnes
intéressées par cette question grave du
bric site et je suis pour ma part
heureux comme un homme politique de
continuer le dialogue que j'ai engagée
avec votre mouvement politique depuis de
très longues années le bris site
c'était une forme de divorce c'est le
choix du royaume uni que que comme je
les dis une fois de devenir solitaire
plutôt que de rester solidaires et c'est
sa responsabilité nous nous avons
regretté
comme quand vous même rebecca vous avez
parlé de ce choc en deux en 2016 mais
nous avons respecté puisque c'est un
choix démocratiquement exprimée par une
majorité de citoyens britanniques et
donc depuis quatre ans patiemment avec
beaucoup de ténacité de respect aussi
nous nous mettons en oeuvre cette
décision pour que on n'en limite les
conséquences parce que d'emblée je veux
dire que le break site c'est l'os
personne n'a été capable depuis quatre
ans je le disais même pas monsieur
farrage que j'ai reçu à sa demande
personne n'était capable de me démontrer
la valeur ajoutée du bric site
donc nous essayons de limiter les
conséquences et nous prenons les choses
dans l'ordre d'abord comme vous l'avez
rappelé le bris sites politiques et
institutionnelles qui est maintenant
fait et puis c'est la négociation
actuelle très difficile le bauxite
économique
une brique sites politiques
institutionnelles nous avons traduit
dans ce que j'appellerais un acte de
divorce ordonné ce traité de près de 600
pages qui apporte des réponses à
d'innombrables questions posées par le
divorce il ya eu tellement de
conséquences de ses décisions pour les
citoyens d'abord je vous le rappelle
trois millions et demi de citoyens
européens qui vivent et travaillent au
royaume uni à un million et demi de
citoyens britanniques qui vivent chez
nous dans l'un des 27 pays de l'union
il fallait et nous l'avons fait
sécuriser les droits de toutes ces
personnes de leur famille pour la durée
de leur vie c'est une assurance
importante
il s'agit que les droits sociaux et tous
les droits de résidence je les ai
organisé le divorce est financier les
britanniques eux participent depuis 47
ans au budget de l'union européenne ils
sont d'ailleurs contributeurs nets ils
n'apportent plus d'argent qu'ils n'en
reçoivent et donc nous avons décidé dans
ce traité de tout ce qui était décidé à
28 avec eux sera bien payés à 28
jusqu'au bout et puis on a trouvé une
solution pour la question la plus
sensible à mes yeux qui est celle la
conséquence la plus grave du bric site
qui est la question de l'irlande où nous
avons une situation très particulière
une île qui était troublé et de manière
grave jusqu'à il ya encore une vingtaine
d'années il n'y a pas eu premiers 500
morts dans cette île dans le conflit
entre les communautés et finalement
grâce au courage politique d'hommes et
de femmes des deux côté républicain mais
unionistes la paix revenue elle s'est
traduite dans un document qui s'appelle
le good friday and women tu l'accord du
vendredi saint et aux termes de cet
accord on coopère entre le sud et le
nord et surtout il ya plus de frontières
et on ne peut pas reconstruire
frontières à sauf à prendre le risque de
nouveaux troubles
tout cela va très bien jusqu'au moment
où une des parties de l'île l'irlande du
nord qui fait partie du royaume uni le
kit le marché unique et l'union
douanière ce qui va se faire avec le
brix
et l'autre partie c'est la république
d'irlande qui restent attachés à l'union
européenne
or nous nous avons je prends juste une
minute pour expliquer le problème
irlandais parce qu'il est sérieux et il
vient d'être réouvert par la décision
assez incompréhensible de boris johnson
et son gouvernement de remettre en cause
sur ce sujet l'accord de retrait qui est
pourtant un traité international signé
et ratifié par le royaume uni pour ça
que nous sommes comme l'a dit notre
présidente ursula von der leyen dans son
discours devant le parlement européen
extrêmement inquiets que nous demandons
que le traité international signé et
ratifié soient bien respectées
le problème c'est quoi c'est que
désormais à cause du bric cite je dis
bien qu une réussite
la limite du marché unique passe au
mieux dit il parce que la partie nord
quittent le marché unique
or nous nous avons et c'est l'essence
même du marché unique qui est bien plus
qu'une zone de libre échange qui est un
écosystème avec des normes des standards
des régulations commune des supervisions
comme une juridiction communautaire au
dessus de tout nous avons une obligation
que nous devons consommateurs que nous
devons aux entreprises c'est celle de
contrôler les produits qui rentrent dans
le marché unique où que ce soit à toutes
les frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne n'est marché unique nous
avons des contrôles pour tous les
produits qui viennent d'ailleurs et donc
nous devons contrôler les produits qui
rentrent en irlande
s'il n'y a pas de frontières au milieu
nous devons contrôler autour de l'île
d'irlande
parce que je veux dire simplement que un
produit quel qu'il soit un animal vivant
une vache qui arrive de grande bretagne
en irlande du nord
elles rendent pas seulement des rentes
du nord elle rend pas seulement
d'irlande cette vache ou se produit il
rentre dans le marché unique
si ya pas de frontières il rentre en
alsace il rentre en belgique il rentre
en allemagne donc nous devons contrôler
pour protéger les consommateurs que nous
faisons et où les produits tous qu'ils
viennent dans le monde
contre les risques de sécurité sanitaire
alimentaire protéger nos budgets des
produits qui viennent de chez nous
d'ailleurs donne droit
quelquefois des tarifs douaniers donc ça
alimente le budget européen le budget
national du pays qui perçoit le tarif
douanier et protéger les industriels par
exemple contre un risque de contrefaçon
voilà ce qu'est le marché unique
pourquoi nous devons protéger et
contrôler et donc ce qu'ils étaient
décidés dans cet accord et que nous
voulons mettre en oeuvre avec le royaume
uni je dis bien avec lui cède des
contrôles techniques des contrôles
douaniers les plus opérationnels et plus
précis possible et c'est ça que qui est
en cause dans la dans la décision du
royaume uni de réouvrir cette discussion
et s'est inséré une question extrêmement
grave voilà donc ce qui est dans ce
traité c'est divorce le break site
institutionnel et politique est
maintenant fait les britanniques sont
sortis ils ne sont plus au parlement ils
sont plus au conseil il ya plus de
commissaire britannique est la deuxième
étape après une classe de transition qui
avaient été accordés entre nous c'est le
31 décembre
on aurait pu aller plus loin mais ils ne
l'ont pas voulu ils vont sortir le 31
décembre
inéluctablement du marché unique et de
l'union douanière la question que nous
étions trancher dans cette négociation
c est ce qu il sortait qu'un accord
commercial un accord sur la sécurité
intérieure dhs accord sur les transports
l'énergie la mobilité des personnes
où est-ce qu'ils sortent sans accord
c'est cet accord que nous essayons de
négocier que j'espère malgré toutes les
difficultés actuelles que nous
réussirons à sidi très bien merci
toutes ces explications claires je tiens
juste à vous dire le président françois
bayrou à nous rejoindre
pendant sept 7 cet échange est en tout
cas connectés
toni kroos
les rouches se connectent une conduite
son engagement européen et aussi de
notre relation amicale très ancienne pas
je reçois déjà quelques quelques
questions des internautes alors je sais
pas présidence et que vous souhaitiez
prendre la parole
sinon peut-être on peut prendre quelques
questions déjà commencé je sais pas vous
entendez
c'est pas si vous m'entendez bon rythme
franchement bonjour bonjour
non je voulais dire simplement que tu
nies devenir doucement la plus
dangereuse la plus stratégique que
sookie dans la place également à
comprendre la nature de lui sa solidité
et aussi des risques est elle tout en
courir et comme toi madinda leur jeu et
c'est tout à fait entendu tes la
prudence de tes propos tu es tu as bien
raison d'adopter cette prudence se
souvenait corrid'oie j'imagine que vous
le tueur la gravité donc seulement de la
décision d epuis le royaume uni mais des
dernières annonces des dernières jury en
qualifiant de boris johnson et donc je
voulais simplement que dire à quel point
on était sensible 1 atteint présence et
de la tomate en soutien de plus que je
peux être
merci françois et rebecca si vous me le
permettez juste
en écho à ce que vient de dire françois
bayrou sur la gravité de cette
négociation
bien sûr il s'agit d'abord de la
relation entre l'union européenne et ce
futur pays tiers ce pays tiers qui est
le royaume uni comme il l'a choisi et si
on met les choses en perspective
ma conviction c'est que nous devons
avoir pour le moyen et le long terme une
relation de coopération et leur rumigny
parce que on affrontera certain nombre
de défis le changement climatique la
lutte contre la pauvreté
la question de la sécurité peut-être la
maîtrise de la finance mondiale
mieux ensemble que chacun chez soi où
chacun de son côté
mais derrière cette d'ego ciation il ya
et c'est ce que vient de dire françois
bayrou
une question plus grave qui est celle de
de l'idée que nous nous faisons de
l'europe et et du projet européen que
certains veulent détruire
il ya des forces à l'oeuvre un extérieur
de l'union européenne contre nous il y
en a aussi à l'intérieur il ya quelques
années deux ans j'ai reçu à sa demande
ce leader du bric si petit monsieur
farrage et je lui demandai à la fin de
notre entretien
vous avez voulu briques site vous l'avez
gagnée nous en prenons acte
nous sommes en train de le faire voilà
le traité qui est en cours de
négociation vous pouvez vous me dire
monsieur marage quel est votre idée pour
la suite après le bric site
comment vous voyez la relation entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni et
il m'a répondu de manière du tac au tac
je barnier mais après le break site
l'union européenne n'existera plus donc
ces gens je dépasse tous les
britanniques n'ont pas tous les briques
sitter je pense que monsieur johnson a
une autre idée mais ces gens veulent
nous détruire
en tout cas monsieur farrage et ses amis
donc on va pas leur laisser un
centimètre pour un pour tenter de nous
détruire et détruire on avait plus beau
projet politique qui ait jamais existé
alors je vais vers midi sur les derniers
propos puisqu'il y avait plusieurs
internautes qui eux ont bien noté
notamment de 13 sur le fait qu' il n'y
ait pas davantage de personnes a été en
mesure de vous dire qu'ils étaient les
éventuels jeu la plus value des briques
site donc une béquille mais qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui par philippe merrheim
c'est donc la question de savoir quel
est le volume finalement l'escroc c'est
le l'impact que ce british daffé avoir
notamment sur les races mus sur la vie
étudiante sur les échanges culturels
pour se promener parce que c'est
peut-être céder kg le premier avec le
plus visible en tout cas pour moi une
partie de la population
alors c'est un des points dont nous
discutons
depuis six mois pour bâtir la future
relation que l'on rubini nous avons une
négociation qui mobilise de mon côté
grâce à la confiance d'ursula von der
leyen je travaille avec 200 personnes
experts parmi les meilleurs de la
commission européenne
il y en a autant du côté britannique et
nous nous réunissons par exemple la
semaine prochaine à nouveau à bruxelles
nous étions à londres il ya quelques
jours c'est une grosse négociations sur
onze tables de négociation les plus
difficiles porte sur le commerce je vais
y revenir si vous le voulez bien parce
qu'il faut comprendre les points durs de
cette négociation
et puis nous avons une négociation sur
les transports aériens routiers
maritimes sur l'énergie sur la mobilité
questions de sécurité sociale est
effectivement surtout des questions de
sécurité intérieure
comment coopérer nous avons besoin de
coopérer sur europol eurojust une des
tables de négociations portent sur les
programmes de l'union qui sont ouverts à
des pays tiers
je rappelle que la suisse ou la norvège
qui sont des pays tiers
israël participe au programme erasmus
suède épreuve de recherche donc nous
ouvrirons si les britanniques le
souhaite et je pense qu'ils le
souhaitent dans certaines conditions le
premier asus ou la coopération rebecca
en matière de recherche et de
coopération universitaire qui est dans
l'intérêt commun
on le voit bien avec tous tes questions
liées aux qu'ovide et aux grands de
grandes pandémies
donc oui ma réponse est claire nous
devons coopérer sur ces sujets pas dans
le même cadre financier ou juridique
mais nous allons coopérer avec le
royaume uni pour la coopération
universitaire et les étudiants alors
dans les questions qui sont vraiment
également il y en a beaucoup qui porte
finalement sur si vous ressentez une
bonne foi de la part de les britanniques
sur des négociations de manière générale
et surtout l'autre qu'on les questions
qui revient c'est en particulier sur les
accords ayant pêché en parlais tout à
l'heure
ah c'est vrai que c'est la question qui
revient beaucoup parce que suscite un
intérêt plus précis et il ya une touche
et après je magasine pris 3 pour être
pour avancer mais en tout cas de vincent
monnier qui l'ont qu'ils vous demandent
s'il est imaginable de poursuivre la
négociation relations futures entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni si
le royaume uni ne respecte pas sa
signature du traité et de la sortie
l'union européenne faisait route de
questions la question que vous posez que
pose vincent meunier liées à la
poursuite de la négociation
elie à la première question sur la bonne
foi
notre choix a été de donner une chance à
cette négociation et aux britanniques
pour aller au bout et trouvé un accord
avec eux parce que nous pensons que
c'est l'intérêt général
mais nous avons dit clairement la
présidente de la commission a dit
clairement comme je charles michel le
président du conseil repère le conseil
des chefs d'état des 27 chefs d'états de
gouvernants le prénom du parlement en
clair monsieur sa solide on dit
clairement que on ne pourrait pas mettre
en oeuvre un nouvel accord international
avec le royaume uni
si le précédent accord l'accord actuel
sur le bric site n'est pas respectée
donc je pense que les britanniques
doivent bien mesurer cette
responsabilité qu'ils ont prises sous
des prétextes et pour des raisons qui ne
sont pas que juste et pas correct sans
doute pour se donner à levier de
négociations supplémentaires
ça ne nous impressionne pas le temps est
tellement court
il faut bien comprendre ça nous devons
conclure cet accord s'il nous en voulons
un dans les quelques semaines qui
viennent sans doute avant la fin octobre
parce qu'après il faut le temps d'une
ratification et le 31 décembre tout doit
être en place donc que parce que votre
intérieur
ils sortent on aurait pu continuer cette
et gociations un ou deux ans des british
ne l'ont pas voulu ils ont voulu sortir
au 31 décembre prochain donc on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps et si on on ne prend
pas tout ce temps chaque jour est utile
chaque semaine est utile pour tenter
d'obtenir cet accord mais mais un
certain moment qui nous avons cet accord
chacun devra prendre ses responsabilités
je pense que les britanniques
nous devons avoir le sens de cette
responsabilité ne serait-ce que
vis-à-vis de leurs signatures sur la
pêche c'est un des sujets graves
il ya trois ou quatre sujets sur
lesquels le la négociation ne progresse
pas parce que les britanniques qui n'ont
pas une position réaliste et parmi ces
sujets il y a la question de la règle du
jeu économique je veux être donné un
explication tout à l'heure sur ce sujet
qui intéresse toutes les entreprises et
les consommateurs
et puis la question de la pêche c'est
vrai que les pêcheurs européens
normandie de bretagne du nord de la
france
belle jeu irlandais allemands
néerlandais danois pour citer les plus
nombreux mais il ya d'autres pays
concernés pêche dans le cadre de la
politique commune des pêches la
politique européenne des pêches ps mais
beaucoup d'espèces dans des eaux
britanniques et ils voudraient nous
exclure complètement de l'euro ce n'est
pas possible et donc le gestion de
trouver un accord et nous avons dit et
je répète que si les britanniques
veulent un accord du commerce comme nous
leur avons proposé un accord
exceptionnellement favorables et changer
nos marchandises sans aucun tarif
douanier et sans aucun quota nous devons
avoir dans ce paquet économique du
commerce géré au tarif 0 cote à un
accord de règle du jeu de fair-play
économique qu'on appelle en anglais
le level playing field et un accord
équilibré sur la pêche et sur 7
deux sujets là qui sont une condition
pour avoir un accord de commerce
nous n'y sommes pas c'est pour ces mêmes
les questions que souhaitez-vous posées
portent plutôt sur les finalement quel
est le modèle européen
alors je joue je resterai différentes
questions mais qu'elle est finalement le
modèle européen qu'on peut imaginer
suite est à ce bric site
certains dans les dans l'ailé les
internautes par l'h2s que des états unis
d'europe et le que c'est quelque chose
qu'ils avaient peut être devenir
imaginables maintenant que le prix de ce
site - lieu il ya toute la question
également d'une europe politiquement
plus intégré
les jours est ce que vous vous y voyez
là le modèle politique peut-être rebecca
si vous me permettez avant de répondre à
cette question plus générale est très
très importante sur le le modèle que
nous voulons je voudrais si la technique
le permet montré une chose qui explique
la difficulté que nous évoque les
britanniques par rapport aux commerces
c'est saïd leylaz est ce que quelqu'un
parce qu'elle peut être montré sur
l'écran à tout le monde de manière plus
le plus éloquente ou pas je ne vois pas
apparaître
mangez-vous la commenter en tout cas
elle est disponible
cette slide c'est tout seuls sur
lesquels sur deux axes nous avons mis ce
sont les boules rouges de couleurs les
qui représentent chacun des pays avec
lesquels nous avons une relation et
commerciales établies dans un accord de
nature différente avec l'état norvégien
s'est par exemple un accord où ils sont
très proches de nous dans le marché
unique et d'autres ce sont des accords
traditionnels de libre-échange la
distance de ces pays
elle est là voyez tout ici le bloc des
pays d'amérique comme le canada ou d'une
année du sud et villes et les pays
d'asie à cliquer nous venons d'accorder
des camps du commerce comme le japon ou
la corée du sud
et puis si les pays européens et puis la
taille de chaque boule représente le
volume des échanges
et qu'est ce qu'on voit sur cette slide
qui est très factuelle
c'est que l'on royaume-uni ici et le
pays tiers désormais qui est le plus
proche de nous 0km en irlande entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni 0km
est celui qui est le volume des changes
le plus important et voilà pourquoi nous
ne pouvons pas être naïf et voilà
pourquoi nous demandons s'il n'y a pas
de tarifs douaniers dans nos échanges a
été britannique
comme c'est souhaitable s'il n'y a pas
de quotas il nous faut des règles du jeu
d'ailleurs sur lesquels avec boris
johnson
nous étions accordé dans le principe il
ya moins d'un an en octobre l'année
dernière pour établir des règles pour la
question des aides d'état
une réunion clause de non régression
dans les normes sociales et
environnementales
c'est ça qui est en cause les
britanniques aujourd'hui nous disent on
ne veut aucune sorte de règle on veut
pas être lié des règles européennes
il s'agit pas de les obliger à nous
suivre il s'agit simplement que eux dans
leur souveraineté et nous dans la nôtre
les pays européens sont souverains et
nous avons souverainement décidé d'être
ensemble dans l'union européenne nous
décidions ensemble de règles pour une
cohérence de nos réglementations éviter
que l'autonomie réglementaire que les
britanniques ont gagné avec le break
site ne se transforme en homme ping
social environnemental fiscales aides
d'état parce que derrière ce dumping si
nous prenions ce risque il y a des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois qui sont
en cause chez nous voilà je les gens
disent là je veux naturellement dire un
mot de votre question plus générale moi
j'ai dans mon engagement politique de
patriotes et d'européens depuis très
longtemps j'ai toujours évité de
d'enfermer l'europe dans un mot je
connais la fibre très très européenne et
quelquefois fédéralistes du modem et
d'autres formations politiques mais de
cette construction européenne est plus
complexe que ça rebecca il ya des
aspects de type fédéral dans la
construction européenne la monnaie
unique est de type fédéral
il ya des aspects des politiques de
nature communautaire où on a mutualisé
d'ailleurs quand on me demande moi quel
est le mot qui caractérise le plus
clairement le projet européen j'emploie
un mot que françois bayroux connais bien
et que les agriculteurs européens et les
français connaissent bien qui est celui
de la mutualisation
nous avons décidé de mutualiser ça veut
dire que l'on mette ensemble
nos politiques dans certains domaines et
même une partie de notre souveraineté
pour avoir une souveraineté européenne
plus forte mais on ne ne fasse pas les
différences on ne gomme pas c'est une
europe unie que nous voulons ce n'est
pas une europe uniforme et il faut
qu'elles respectent cette europe les
identités nationales les cultures les
traditions c'est pas un gros mot ou
l'identité nationale donc voilà je
voudrais éviter qu on ouvre des débats
sur des mots et en revanche qu'on
intègre davantage nos politiques oui on
le voit bien y compris dans les domaines
comme l'actualité le montre tragiquement
qui suit la santé nous avons besoin
d'une compétence européenne dans le
domaine de la santé pour coordonner la
recherche il coordonner les réponses en
cas de grandes pandémies parce que
malheureusement il y en aura d'autres
avec les échanges et la mondialisation
dans les haies et le réchauffement
climatique dans l'est dans les années
qui viennent donc je veux simplement
marquer mon assentiment mon accord
complet avec lui chez ce dernier vient
de glisser qu'il n'est pas digne formule
t alors lui sait depuis longtemps que
nous pensons la même chose ce point et
sur bien d'autres aussi d'ailleurs mais
c'est très important de ne pas se
laisser embarquer dans des débats qui
sont des débats qui monte à l'issue d'un
côté et qui sont dangereux de notre côté
pour le pour le pour le projet qui est
le nôtre et donc de ce point de vue la
trêve
[Musique]
le fait d'être pragmatique d'ailleurs de
nous interdit pas d'être ambitieux pour
l'europe et on voit bien que il faut
l'être sinon qu'avec vous de vous le
dire on est foutu je je je le dis
clairement je vais vous montrer un
deuxième slag mais je la technique ne
vous les montre pas mais je voudrais
juste parce que ça ça vaut mieux que des
discours
ce tableau il a été fait par david
cameron vous vous souvenez de icc
d'anciens pros ministre britannique au
moment du référendum et il avait à
l'époque voulu démontrer l'importance
d'être ensemble d'être dans le marché
unique et ce tableau il montre le g8 les
huit pays économiquement les plus
puissants du monde aujourd'hui à quatre
pays européens sont dans le g8
l'allemagne évidemment le royaume-uni la
france et l'italie et aux rythmes
probable de l'évolution économique des
uns et des autres dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
parfois on espère encore les européens
mais plus personne ne nous attend plus
personne ne nous demande la permission
et bien au rythme de l'évolution
probable
tous les dix ans il y en a un des quatre
qui est éjecté du tableau et et en 2050
c'est demain matin et là plus qu'un quel
dernier c'est l'allemagne
moi j'ai utilisé les mêmes chiffres j'ai
été actualisés pour montrer ce que ça
donne si on est ensemble en bleu ou si
on est seul comme au royaume uni si on
est ensemble on a une chance même si on
recule un peu
personne ne nous attend on a en rel dans
le g8 on reste à la table on reste
acteurs de notre propre destin et pas
spectateur de notre destin mais en
revanche le royaume-uni ici tout seul
sera inédit nerveusement exclus de la
table du g8 comme nous même si nous
restons seuls
donc c'est pour ça que dans un ensemble
de domaines c'est pas un choix d'être
européen si si on veut être influent si
on veut compter si on veut éviter d'être
sous influence des chinois ou des
américains et et sous traitants pour
être très clair
moi je me suis pas engagé en politique
quand j'étais très jeune pour le général
de gaulle ça reste ma principale fierté
pour être mon pays soit sous traitants
et sous affluents soir
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
j'ai donc j'en attends quelques minutes
au corps d'autres questions qui le sauve
remontée est en moi je peux dire que et
j'espère que vous me pardonnerez mais je
ne peux m'empêcher de vous poser une
question qui est notamment lié à
strasbourg et à la france ça n'amène
portes volets la session européenne du
parlement européen n'a pas pu se faire
pour des raisons sanitaires et à la
colline le sujet avec temps pas de
débattre là dessus mais j'ai questionné
toute simple c'est juste est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement on ne vend pas est
ce qu'on risque vraiment de perdre le
siège européen à strasbourg
et voilà quels sont à votre avis les
moyens qui nous permettraient oui j'ai
vu ressortir ce débat à l'occasion de la
décision qui a été prise objective et
pragmatique de ne pas tenir la prochaine
cession ou la cession de la semaine
dernière plutôt à strasbourg mais
c'était difficile vous l'avez vous même
dit que plusieurs milliers de personnes
viennent travailler à strasbourg comme
on le fait chaque mois et puisse obliger
en revenant de d'être en quarantaine à
bruxelles donc je pense que c'est une
décision objective qui a été prise par
le parlement européen
de 10 à l'intérêt général pour le reste
franchement ce ce débat n'est pas ouvert
il ne pourrait être ouvert que dans le
cas d'une unanimité des 27 pays et des
27 gouvernements ce n'est pas le cas et
je moi je recommande vraiment qu'on
mobilise notre énergie notre
intelligence notre notre force sur les
grands sujets d'aujourd'hui comme l'a
dit ursula von der leyen dans son
discours s'agissant de la force de
l'europe de son autonomie de sa force
numérique industrielle qu'il faut
construire ou reconstruire
s'agissant du green deal de du
développement durable une changement
climatique on a tellement dessus
pour mobiliser l'énergie des genres bien
que celui là je recommande de dalé
d'aller à l'essentiel si je puis dire un
merci
d'autres questions présent je sais pas
si vous souhaitez très bien notamment
sur la question de la monnaie
une des questions qui se posent pour
revenir c'est de savoir si est alors
elles mettront alors la rencontre dans
beaucoup de si mais si un jour les
britanniques souhaitent réintégrer
l'union européenne dans les débats qui
ne sont pas toujours ouvrir celui ci est
peut-être vrai monde en maître inspecté
mais s'il souhaite revenir pensez vous
que d'autres finalement la question qui
vous est posée c'est de savoir si on
pourrait changer et ce qu'ils devront
quitter par exemple abandonné la livre
parce que regarder les avantages revenir
ces débats un peu ouverte ils sont
vraiment dans il faut être réaliste le
un pays tiers européen peut toujours
demander à rejoindre ou à rejoindre
l'union européenne
certains l'ont demandé ont finalement
refusé comme par exemple la norvège il
ya des débats en suisse c'est la faire
de chaque peuple que de décider de sa
relation si le brix ita non pas une
valeur ajoutée j'ai dit qu'il n'en avait
aucune mais au moins en terme de
pédagogie et de leçon pour tout le monde
c'est de montrer qu'on n'est pas une
prison on peut ressortir et donc les
britanniques entre choisi d'en sortir et
chacun prend ses responsabilités en
assumant les conséquences mais c'est pas
une prison donc on peut on peut
rejoindre cet ensemble de pays souverain
qui décident de partager de mutualiser
leurs destins et la porte est toujours
ouverte aux pays européens
néanmoins je pense qu'il faut aussi des
frontières pour que les choses soient
claires le projet européen de l'union
européenne est elle un pays qui concerne
notre continent européen
donc je ne peux pas faire d'autres
spéculations franchement on n'est pas du
tout dans cette situation là on est la
situation le bric site s'est fait en
partie va se terminer
ou plutôt commencer le président va
commencer d'ébrité ils vont vivre leur
propre destin mr solitaire à partir du
1er janvier prochain et on verra bien ce
qui se passe après mais nous nous devons
nous devons garder notre capacité d'agir
ensemble de capacités d'attractivité je
pense
si michel daniel permet ne sais pas si
vous m'entendez
oui je voudrais simplement ajouter un
mot parce que on vit les événements les
uns après les autres et on est au plus
près on perd assez souvent la
perspective historique ni contrainte à
deville réfléchir je crois profondément
on a eu comme vous vous en souvenez le
référendum le traité de maastricht
si difficile mais il ya une question
toute simple
où en serions nous aujourd'hui si la
banque centrale européenne n'existait
pas on n'aurait une monnaie nationale
qui serait l'objet d'attaqués
spéculatives imandt et il était il
aurait été totalement exclu que nous
puissions disposer par la création des
tapis à l'étude et la banque centrale
européenne des crédits nécessaires pour
le plan de relance et de sauvegarde de
renard ce n'est pas remis des n'est plus
de 100 milliards qui ont été investis
par le gouvernement français pour
sauvegarder ou font l'unité sociale du
pays face à cet immense crise
ça n'a été rendu possible que parce que
il y avait qu il existait une banque
centrale européenne jean à protéger
comme que les grandes banques centrales
européennes du monde
les trois ou quatre banques centrales
otage leur peuple si nous n'avions pas
eu cet ensemble européen nous aurions
été abandonnée un sort qui aurait été à
coup sûr d'aller souffler dans
l'oreillette que mon devoir
mais l'essai répond de michel d'abord
difficile dans les minutes de parler
mais des leçons et des conséquences du
brics ip évidemment françois a raison on
voit bien d'ailleurs
au delà de la gestion de la crise et du
rôle de la banque centrale que catillon
vous regarde le monde tel qu'il est ou
tel qu'il va et notamment ce que
l'ancien président de la république
après la finance mondiale voilà un sujet
qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser certaines
dérives dont on ne peut pas se protéger
chacun chez soi chacun pour soi il ya
600 mille milliards six cent mille
milliards de dollars qui circulent au
dessus de nos têtes dans la plus grande
opacité la spéculation comment on se
protège et si on n'a pas à se dire
pourquoi
selon de spéculateurs n'aime pas la
monnaie unique parce que nous sommes un
ensemble la zone euro et l'union
européenne avec des règles communes de
la gouvernance commune des réactions
commune et c'était une manière de se
protéger aussi contre les conséquences
négatives
il y en a quelques unes de la
mondialisation et peut-être pour
conclure il ya un homme politique
français de la quatrième république que
pour lequel j'avais beaucoup de respect
c'était pierre mendès-france et un jour
pierre mendès-france a écrit dans je
crois que c'est un discours à la
jeunesse ne jamais sacrifier l'avenir au
présent jamais sacrifier l'avenir au
présent et moi dans cette négociation
que j'ai l'honneur de conduire sous
l'autorité de prison de la commission de
conseil des chefs d'état du parlement
qui va se terminer à la fin de cette
année après je vais revenir modestement
et avec énergie pour reprendre ma place
dans le débat politique français
je pense toujours à cette phrase et
j'essaie de mettre en perspective cette
négociation notamment sur trois points
rebecca que je veux rappeler parce que
ils sont importants et c'est le mot de
perspectives que françois utiliser la
première perspective historique et
d'avenir c'est celle de la paix en
irlande
on ne peut pas prendre de risques et
c'est notre responsabilité
la deuxième perspective c'est celle de
la coopération nécessaire avec le
royaume uni qui reste un grand pays qui
diplomatie une défense une économie
importante et nous avons besoin de cette
coopération si on regarde les choses à
moyen ou long terme pour faire face à ce
manque de challenge et de défis mondiaux
avec le royaume uni d'une autre manière
qu'aujourd'hui mais j'ai cette
perspective là en tête et puis là d'un
troisième et l'essai de l'europe c'est
c'est ce marché unique et nos valeurs de
grâce je vous ai montré le tableau sur
le g8 ne prenons aucun risque le marché
unique c'est notre principal atout
la raison pour laquelle monsieur trompe
ou le présent chinois nous respecte
c'est ce marché unique de 450 millions
de consommateurs citoyens de 22 millions
d'entreprises
donc il ya plein de choses à changer il
ya des leçons du break site a tiré une
colère sociale qui s'est exprimé au
royaume-uni contre l'europe est en fait
contre la mondialisation
cette colère il existe aussi dans
beaucoup de régions françaises en
belgique que dans d'autres pays il faut
faire attention ne pas confondre le le
sentiment populaire cette colère sociale
avec le populisme et écouter tirer des
leçons
comme nous sommes en train dé tir au
niveau européen c'est tout n'est pas
parfait il n'ya pas le soin à tirer mais
et de grâce ne remettant pas en cause ce
projet européen d'une europe unie pas
uniforme et d'une de l'ensemble europe
et où je pense notre pays est plus fort
parce qu'il est solidaire des autres
pays européens
[Musique]
2 l occasion de revenir le dimanche à
mon bureau et donc je suis très heureux
de cette occasion voyais offerte
on a une rude semaine qui vient de deux
futurs semaine dans ce très difficile
voilà donc il faut être en forme
merci à tous en tout cas je suis prêt à
continuer ce dialogue avec vous à
bientôt et habite au françois